what is up welcome to the 26th PHP
tutorial is when we're going to be
talking about die and exit the point of
dying exit is to stop the script when
you can't do a function it's kind of
like the difference between include and
require so if you try to do something
and you can't get it you might want to
use die like if you have an integral
variable that needs to be defined in it
for whatever reason didn't get defined
you might want to kill the script so to
give you an example of this let's say
you have let it pass equals password and
then you've got let's just say that ok
another we want to echo username and
then we want to echo a password so
obviously we've not defined user name
yet and then we want to echo password
then we want to do some stuff let's
savor them we want to do stuff with
username and password obviously we can't
because we don't actually have a
username but what happens when we go to
echo this stuff it still echoes password
even though really it broke at username
you didn't have a username so what can
we do if you know username doesn't exist
we don't want to go on to a password so
a good example of this is when you try
to connect to a database if you can't
connect to the database to display data
there's no point to go through all the
operations of displaying data if you
couldn't connect eight of its right so
let's just do a simple database
connection so that's just going to be my
sequel or SQL underscore connect and
within a kinetic function you just have
three parameters and those parameters
are going to be the host name then
you've got username and then you have
password
obviously this isn't going to work
because that's not a proper hostname
that's not a username and that's not a
very good password and so it doesn't
actually exist so let's just say we want
to do that and then we'll say we'll just
do that and then echo just echo you know
like act like we've connected at this
point so another good idea to do and
what I'm going to do since it's on one
of my servers is if you get an error
with an a my sequel connection it's
going to actually display the error on
page and so it gives the whole directory
of whatever this page is and so on so
you might not want to do that for
security purposes so whenever you're
just developing on your own it's okay
but if you actually have like a public
script you might want to put the at sign
in front of that and that'll kind of
silence the air so I'll show you what
that means in a second but we'll just
save that and put that up so that's not
going to work but still it yells out
connected right to us even though this
is just a whole bunch of BS information
right so really what we want to do is
add one more bit of code to this and
that code is going to be or die and
within die you want to you can put you
can just leave a blank or you could
throw in some text but first let's just
use this die and see if we actually get
echo of connected so we refresh and as
you can see nothing happens right
because we obviously did not connect but
then we don't to die you can kind of use
it as a way to report your own errors
instead of having them my sequel report
the air for you so you could say or die
and failed to connect to the DB so now
we'll save that and we'll run this and
you'll see it reports our error message
and then stops the script so that's kind
of a useful function that to use when
your especially connecting to a database
where you can't connect to that database
you definitely want to die because you
know you can't really do too much else
if you haven't connected to your
database so anyway
that's died and it's basically the same
thing exit I'll just show you will save
this and then we'll use an exclamation
point just to show you that it did
indeed change come over hoops come over
here refresh and again failed to connect
to DV really does the same exact thing
so anyways that's dying exit I hope you
guys enjoy and stay tuned to next video